[Music]
i was born in texas
um my mom uh ventured out when she was
18
to go to you know someplace other than
her hometown
she ended up in texas where she met my
father
she ended up getting pregnant with me a
couple years later
my dad actually left uh while my mom was
having having me um my mom was forced to
go back to indiana
with her parents where i grew up
um she raised me alone
you know she was a single parent she did
a really
great job at raising me you know i had
morals and ethics and
and i learned how to treat people the
way that i wanted to be treated
you know i was i was a really bad kid
i was always getting in trouble because
i didn't have any male role model
in my life to give me any kind of
discipline i think
and by the time i was 12 i was
you know getting kicked out of school
and getting in trouble all the time and
getting put on probation and different
things like that
when my father came back when i was 12
years old he came back for a very short
period of time where he was
trying to be trying to be back in my
life but he uh
he ended up just passing away like from
a heart failure
my mom was left to raise me by herself
you know and she did the best that she
could but i was
a really bad kid you know um
i was 16 when i started using
drugs because i was uh
i had an injury to my leg i was in a
pretty bad car accident
and i was also in a i was also in a
i had a football injury where i blew my
other knee out
so i got onto pain medication at that
time
when um
you know i started using vicodins and
different things like that just to
you know to ease the pain i thought is
what i was doing but
i didn't realize it was going to cause
so many problems later on
um my mom was diagnosed with cancer
when i was 17.
she ended up beating that first round of
cancer
but she uh also passed away a few years
later
from from cancer as well when i was
incarcerated
i was 18 years old when i've caught my
first charge as an adult
i was literally like one week into my
18th birthday
um i didn't want to go to jail i got
caught with viking or not biking i got
caught with ecstasy
and other pain pills as well
they sentenced me to uh do two years on
probation
but i violated within a year
and i took off and
didn't really come back until i was in
my in my mid-20s
um my family
exported drugs from another country it
was in portugal
and i always wondered what my dad's side
of the family did for a living
they drove really expensive cars and
never went
never worked and never went to a
nine-to-five job
and i always ask them like what what
they did you know what how did
they support themselves and i found out
later on that
that my family was manufacturing a drug
called methaqualone
which is uh quaaludes for
you know another name for those
quaaludes when i was on the run
from my first charge i was able to
get out of the country and move to
portugal
where i learned how to manufacture this
drug
and i did that for for many years for
seven years
until my uncle passed away from cancer
as well
left me you know i planned on making uh
millions of dollars and being able to
retire at a very young age but
it just didn't end up working out that
way um
when he passed away i was kind of left
with nothing
my his wife took all the chemicals and
all the glassware and ended up selling
it to somebody
that was outside of my family and i was
left to
basically my own devices no money no
way to make you know a dollar i didn't
know what i was going to do
you know so i went back home uh
ended up catching another charge for
possession
um when i went to the that last time
that i spent in jail i
was doing a two-year do one sentence
and uh i met a guy in there who talked
about heroin
and and i always thought that heroin was
like the the the biggest no-no the
biggest
thing that you shouldn't do and and
anybody that did it was just like
you know not a good person you know
but when i got out of jail
i hit that person up and he offered to
take me
to another state to go get some heroin
one day
uh which i you know i thought about it
for a while but i ended up going and
driving him to ohio which is where we
were
gonna go and get this heroin i guess um
when the first time i tried heroin like
it was like
the greatest thing that's ever been
created by god you know
it was something that uh that changed my
life
entirely you know it uh
it was like a warm hug from my mom from
my mother
you know it's what it reminded me of
something that just like kept me warm
and fuzzy and and it made me feel like
there was like
never gonna be anything else that was
any better
you know uh so
at that time i was living in a small
town where
you know nobody really did heroin you
know they they were smoking pot and
and eating pills and doing things like
that but when i
discovered heroin i thought it was the
greatest thing in the world so i wanted
all my friends to try it you know and
all my friends to experience what
i was experiencing as well you know so
uh i brought my first few bags of
everyone into this
little small town where everybody knows
who who you are and you know it's uh
pretty uh pretty crazy to think that
like
within like a year's time i was like
known as like the heroine king
of this little small town you know like
every i had everybody coming to me and
getting bags and
you know like i started getting watched
by the police and
things were going downhill pretty
quickly
you know because i was using all the
time and and uh
you know constantly like trying to to
figure out what's next and
and and living a lifestyle like
like like a rock star almost in my
opinion
like i had a uh awesome car
had a beautiful girlfriend tons of money
uh and i was just living
what i thought was going to be the rest
of my life
but again it just didn't turn out that
it didn't
turn out the way that i expected it to
uh
i uh
got arrested for something it's pretty
petty
in my opinion it was just the vicodin
and when i got charged with vicodin i
got
sentenced to do a two do one sentence
um but it was uh suspended due to
probation different things
that i had to complete for classes and
and things like that
um i ended up meeting my wife shortly
after that
she didn't want me to go to jail so i
ended up moving into her little small
town
and started selling heroin to all the
people in
that small town also
the wife that i met was something that
was like
you know she was 19 i was 25
something like that 24 23
something in that that area um and
i just fell in love with her and uh
she was like my little body and clyde i
guess they were just going out and
doing destructive [ __ ] and buying heroin
and selling it to all her friends and
you know
making lots of money but uh
we both had a terrible habit you know
pretty shortly after that the police
came
to uh her little small town where i was
living in
and uh ended up arresting me for the
violation of probation that i had and
she took me to jail when i got
incarcerated for that last time it was
uh pretty hard because
my mom you know who's the only parent
that i've ever had was
diagnosed with cancer again she they
only gave her a year to live
and i was gonna have to do a year in
jail
i uh did most that time
you know like i was on a work release
program
so i was out in the world every day and
and
life wasn't so bad uh until
i ended up catching my wife cheating on
me with one of my closest friends
uh she ended up actually
trying to turn me in to get me to do
more jail time
she met me she met me somewhere on on
when i was on work release and dropped
off some things for me to
bring back into the work release
and she called the police and told them
i was bringing things in
and i almost got sentenced to another 10
years or so for bringing things into the
jail
luckily i uh
smart enough to kind of figure out how
to to sit and wait and
wait for my opportunity to get rid of
what i needed to get rid of
so that i wouldn't end up having to do
that time
um they sat in jail for probably nine
months out of that year
and they sentenced me to go to a rehab
went to my first rehab which was at a
mental hospital in indiana
um was there for a month
you know at that time that's when i went
to the hospital and
my mom and the doctor and the families
and everything
was there and they told her that you
know she didn't have very
long to live like weeks to a month
something like that
i was very angry and didn't really know
what
i was gonna do but you know the the
rehab was
extremely uh
not receptive for me going and seeing
her so they
escorted me to the hospital in handcuffs
and would not leave the room for my last
visit with my mom
you know it's really hard
um they escorted me back to the rehab
and
at that time my wife showed up and
she was uh told me it was my birthday
actually
and she told me that uh she showed up
she was extremely late
three four hours late and when she
showed up she was all [ __ ] up
um i made her pull her arm her sleeves
up and that's when i found out she was
using heroin again
and uh i ended up getting into a fight
with one of the
people at the rehab because you know i
just found out my mom was gonna have a
few weeks left to live
i just found out my wife was using
heroin again
and that's when i kind of snapped
you know and and beat one of the the
guys that was working there half to
death
uh they took me in a room and i didn't
know what was going to happen and then
they sent me back to jail the very next
day
you know no credited time of the months
that i've been there
you know and when i went home
or when i went back to jail i had no
idea when i was going to be released
no idea when my mom was gonna pass away
and i actually got sentenced to do
another nine months
in jail um at that time
you know i had nobody putting money on
my books and nobody helping me
so i was angry i was i was hungry
you know and and i was doing what i had
to do to to get by
i had some some guy there it was uh
uh i'll never forget this he ended up
there was a time where we were switching
out this ice bucket in the
in the jail because we had like one ice
bucket a day that we could use for
the whole day and this guy came up to me
and
as i was changing this ice bucket and he
spilled a whole cup of water over my
head
you know and he was laughing and
thinking it was hilarious
and i just turned
red i couldn't see anything besides
blood man
and i started fighting this guy and he
got him on the ground and beat him
until he was [ __ ] black and blue and
uh the police ran
you know police came in and uh ended up
putting me in solitary confinement for
six months to sell by myself
no idea of anything like i had no money
to order
anything no commissary no nothing no
phone calls
it was just me in a cell by myself and
uh
and uh around nine months or so later
you know like i had a they just came in
my cell one day and told me to pack my
stuff up
and i had no idea why or what was going
on but i was being released
and when they released me my
grandparents were there and they took me
back to their house where my mom was and
i got to spend
a few hours with her before she ended up
passing away
uh when she passed away she left me some
money so that i could take care of
myself for
you know that's supposed to be a longer
period than it was but
[Music]
i ended up spending all the money on
drugs
on heroin
[Music]
at that time my wife got a job we were
we were working both working at a uh
a gold place where i was flying a sign
for like eight hours a day
um she ended up getting a job inside
um with the the gold place and ended up
uh chanted up like
ended up sleeping with a guy that was uh
running this gold shop
so that's what kind of split our
relationship up
i got back with her again later on and
uh
uh on thanksgiving i was visiting my
family because
you know my my family didn't accept my
wife and
my they didn't her family didn't really
like me either so we were doing separate
thanksgivings
and uh i gotta i went and did my family
thing and came home
and when i came home i got a phone call
from a friend's girlfriend
that was telling me that my wife was
sleeping with her
husband right now and at the whole time
i thought she was with
her family but i ended up going to
where they were and beating this guy
half to death
[Music]
my wife got into a fight with the
girlfriend of this other gentleman and
and uh that was kind of the end of our
relationship
you know after my wife uh i called her
with my friend
and uh luckily he didn't call i mean the
police came
um they were on the way as i was leaving
i could hear them coming
and we luckily i got away i went back to
my house
and uh i called my aunt who lives here
in los angeles and uh
told her what was going on and she flew
me out here to la
shortly after that my wife had called me
and told me she was pregnant
and that it was my kid so
you know i told her that i would be
there for her as much as i could
and if the kid was mine that i would i
would go back to indiana i would be with
her
nine months passed and not only was
the child not my friends or mine the
child came out black
not that i'm racist or anything at all
but it was just
definitely not my child you know um
so needless to say that was the end of
my marriage
um i was broken man like
lost my wife lost my mother all within
like a year
spanned and i
i started using heroin it's really heavy
um my aunt here is like
a saint man like she's done everything
that she's could to like try to get me
out of the drug game and trying to get
me on a normal path
but it's just not it's not happened
you know she's had me in and out of
rehabs and different places that she
thought was gonna
change me but i always end up back
on the streets back using drugs and
selling drugs and
in and out of jail
[Music]
since then you know i've moved on to
fentanyl
heroin just wasn't doing it for me
anymore
you know i was doing black tar heroin at
the time and it just wasn't
it wasn't getting me to the point where
it was when i first started using
um fentanyl took me right back to that
first time that i did heroin
you know it gave me everything i was
looking for
but it's also uh it's also ruined my
life man
you know i've not been able to do
anything besides
sell drugs and and
and uh lie to my family ever since
you know i've been homeless for the
first time
this year you know six months ago i had
fifty thousand dollars in the bank
i was selling fentanyl to everybody
that that ever heard of it you know
but um
[Music]
pandemic hit after the pandemic hit
i was just unemployed i
started using drugs even heavier than i
ever had before
um kind of left now trying to figure out
what's what's next
you know so i've been homeless now for
just a
few months staying with some friends but
i still consider myself homeless i'm in
a place that i really don't want to be
i'm dealing with people that i don't
want to deal with
you know spending time on skid row for
the first time in my life
where i would never have thought that i
would ever be
you know and
i'm basically just waiting to figure out
what's next
you know and i hope that something
eventually changes so that i can
stop using this drug man because i hate
it
i hate the way it's made me become
you know i don't care about anything
besides staying well
and trying to put a roof over my head
that's about where i'm at today you know
all right phil thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah good luck with
everything man thanks man i appreciate
it you've been through a lot
i'm sure there's more to come but i hope
i can get through all this
[ __ ] man
[Music]
all right thanks